で こちらにあるこのストーリーはもうだいたいなんででしょうかね
いつでも合わないストーリーつなげちゃうんですよ
で 本当はこの芸とストーリーは全然関係ないんで
私はほとんど言わないんですけどね
それをみんなに嫌われてる一つの理由であの
なんか大きなダンマパダ本が日本語できてまで
この人を私に言ったら
このストーリーが一番大事ですよと
バカじゃないかと思ったんですけどね
で ストーリーが合わないんですけどね
で この因縁話はね で 後で付けたもんですよ
もう このダンマパダ偈は別に経典にあるしね
偈とストーリーぴったし合うのはもうジャータカ物語だけなんです
ダンマパダのストーリーはもう強引に付けたもんですよ
こちらなるストーリーはある
もう農業をやっている田んぼを作っている人がいて
お釈迦様はまあこの人は悟れる能力あるんだと
で しかし ものすごい不幸になる業もあるんだと
だから私は何とかしてあげて
悟れるようにしなくちゃいけないんだということで
あの人は朝もう田んぼを作っているところに
お釈迦様 アーナンダ尊者と一緒に行くんです
前の日 泥棒たちが強盗やって
そこら辺でこの財産を分けたみたいですね
夜だから あの 言いますけど
日本の夜と違いますから
昔の夜はね 電気はないんですからね
それで泥棒は電気なくてもどっかいド派手に光り明けてあげて仕事するわけでもないでしょうに
微かな光を作ったり使ったりするかもしれませんですけどね
微かな光で財産を分けて分けて
それでみんな泥棒たちはちゃんと分配して出て行っちゃったんです
それで金が入っている一袋を忘れちゃったんです
で 金貨全工入っていたと言いますけど
まあまあかなりお金入ったと思いましょう
でも泥棒だから まあ奪ったもんだから
そうわからないでしょうね
どれぐらいあったかとか
何とも で みんな全部お金分けたということで出ていったんですけど
一つ落ちていたんですね
この人の田んぼのそばなんです
お釈迦様が朝早くそちらに行って
もうあの人とちょっと挨拶して喋ってどうですかとかね
まあ仕事しています 頑張ってくださいと
言って お釈迦様はあの泥棒たちいた木のところに行って
アーナンダ長老に「アーナンダ
あんたこの蛇見えますか？」と
あんたに ちょっと聞こえる声で言うんで
アーナンダ この蛇がいるの見えますかと
はい 尊師 蛇ですねと言って答えたんです
言って出て行ったんですね
そこでこの田んぼを作っている人
はっ 蛇とお釈迦様に言われたんだから
これ危ない もう 何とかしなくちゃっていうことで
なんか棒を持ってそちらに行ったんです
行ったらなんだ 蛇じゃなくてなんか袋なんですね
それを持ってどこか別なところに掛けておいて
また田んぼに戻って仕事を始めたんだと
それで王様の家来が来て
泥棒ということで この後を追っていったところで金見つけて
それでその人はその場所に行った足跡もちゃんとあって
お前は泥棒の一人だと
これお前の取りもんだと
で 捕まったんですね 捕まってもこの人は私はもういいなと言ったし
何も言いませんね で やられちゃったんだから
まあ一応首を飛ぶ羽目になっちゃったんです
だったら何かいいことはありますかと言うと
あればっかし言うんですね
アーナンダ 蛇を見えますかと
はい 尊師 蛇ですねと そればっかり言うと
王様はお釈迦様のこと知っていたんだから
王様にそういうこと この人は何かおかしいんだと
こんなこと言ってるのは何言ってるのかといったら
こう言う あら これはブッダの言葉でしょうと
言って もうもう殺す前に御寺に連絡して
まあ言ったらアーナンダ尊者が来て
そういうことはありましたと
この人は関係ないということで
お坊さんの承認で一応解放してもらったんですね
それで その人はもうこのお金のことで自分が死ぬ運命になったんだと
だからお金っていうのはとんでもない危ないことであると思って
もうお坊さんのところに行って説法を聞いて悟りを開いたという話なんですね
それはそれで別のお話としてすごくありがたい話ですけど
後で後悔することはするなよという話には合わないんです
ということには何の役にも立たないエピソードなんです
私はそのエピソードというのは
財産は本当は毒蛇であるということが一番ありがたい言葉なんですよ
財産では後で悩む羽目になるんだよという風に
別に経典でそういう風に繋げてあります
実際のエピソードの場合は
我々は金やら財産やら
あらゆる財産というのはなんてすごい楽しいでしょうかと思いますけど
それは毒蛇のようなものであると
だから使い方に 取り扱い方には厳密に注意しなくちゃいけないものなんです
人間は注意しないのは財産扱いなんですね
家族に対して 自分のお金に対して
こういう財産というものを人間に喜びを与えてくれると思っているものに対しては
全く注意ないんですね
で 無茶苦茶にやる 音楽聴こうと思っちゃうと
無茶苦茶もうバカになって音楽は聴くわ
酒飲もうと思っちゃうと無茶苦茶バカになってやるわ
賭け事に行っちゃうとパチンコに行っちゃうと
もう全部捨てて投げ捨ててそれやるわ
遊び事になっちゃうと
もう何の管理もなくもう遊んじゃうわ
一番注意必要なこの毒蛇なんですよ
パチンコに行くなよではなくて
それ自体が毒蛇であるということは知っておかないと
音楽の演奏会に行ってもいいんだけど
はい 次はどこでやってますか？次はどこでこの人やってますか？とかね
あるいはどこかで渋谷
新宿どこで演奏会と毎日のようにあるでしょう
ホールはいつでももう使用中だから
だからまあ東京のあのオーケストラ演奏をやっているあのビルがありますね
どこかで 東京都の で そちらも毎土曜日
毎日曜日やってます いろんな有名な人やら有名でない人やら
もういろんな人をかけてやってます
ホールは空いてる日はないんです
だから言って一回行っただけで
全部今月その催し物とあれリストまで次から次へと来るっていうのはとんでもないことでしょう
だからこの そういう財産というものに対しては
仏陀は毒蛇という感じで気をつけなさいと
[背景音楽]このコウモリとかね
毒蛇はもう噛まれたら死にますけど
もう触ったりすることできますよ
ちゃんと知ってる人だったら
コウモリに噛まれたらもう確実に死にますけど
でもコウモリを手で取ったりすることはできます
私たちにはできませんよ
まず怖いでしょうに 怖いんだから
なんか近寄るんだから
蛇が一気に興奮しちゃうんですね
興奮しちゃうと反射でパスってやっちゃうんです
この扱う人々はもう興奮させません
ずっと寝ているんだからね
だからもう触る前に よく慣れてるような慣れさせた振動にね
その慣れているような振動を出して
蛇が目が覚めているし
で 何のことなくゆっくりと取ったりする
時々蛇はもう取っているんですけど
それでも寝ている場合もあります
それで打ったり それからまた元に戻す時でも
何のこと自分で軽く巻いてあげたっても
蛇は何の心配することもなく
そのまま いきなりこうやって音を出せちゃうと
パッともう顔上げても攻撃する
だけど いろんなこの専門家はね
何のことなく蛇を 自分の国の大学で専門家の教授がいて
蛇の蛇に対して専門家医者なんですね
で みんなもう もうすごくもうなんていますか
ひたすら好きというか
ものすごいこの教授はね
もう年の割にいろいろ講義講演をやってる時でも
何のことなくもうポケットに手を入れて
えらもう毒の蛇とか出したりするんですね
で あの授業講義授業に必要なサンプルはもう自分のポケットに
自分のポケットに持って行くんです
だからあの先生に近寄るなよと
話だけ遠くから話を聞いて勉強して帰りなさいっていうのは
みんな学生の間では 近寄ったらどうされるかわかりませんと
それでわざとふざけたことやりたいんだから
それを持って行って あちこち歩いたりしながら
じゃああんたどうでしょう
じゃあこちらのこのキバはこうあってとか
こういう顔のそれ 触ってごらんとかね
あれはわざとまあまあふざけてね
まあそういうことないと
大体頭がね まあもう立派な先生だと思いますけどね
なんかクソ真面目で教えちゃうと
学生たちは頭悪いまんまで終わりますからね
教授は 80%イカれてるんだよと分かった方が
生徒たちはすごく勉強するんです
教えるものはもう忘れられ
もうそのまま覚えてるんだからね
もう一人の教授が歴史家でね
もうお年でしたけどね
私が知ってる時はね でももう一人者で
もう大量に研究論文出したりして
もうものすごいんです
で まあ年も年でしょうし
そんなにもうすごい真剣に授業ということでもないんです
一応セミナーみたいなこともやったりして
研究する学生に 一般学部 の生徒たちにはほとんど授業しません
で これで生徒たちが自分の研究レポートいろいろやってるんだから
先生にとって面白くも何ともないんです
それ一人者で一人一人者だからね
もう面白くもないし 分析は正しくはないし
もう だからといってね
聞いてあげなくちゃいけないし
間違いこれはダメっていうことはダメでしょうし
いくらか点数あげないと
それまとめて最初の卒業で関係ありますからね
ある日  2人ぐらい自分の研究読んだところ
先生はグーグーと寝てるんです
寝てるとみんな先生寝てるんだから
あの年だから何もことなくみんなゆっくり一人一人出ていく
これ先生逆にからかってやるぞと思ってるんです
先生目が覚めてみると
自分のセミナーで一人もいないと
先生すごい恥ずかしくなるでしょうね
で こう後ろから一人一人一人抜けてはいくんですけど
もう一人あんまり下手な若者が抜けようと思ったところで
デスクに体触れちゃったんです
たら音が出るでしょうね
音が出て先生目が覚めてこいついきなり捕まっちゃったんです
もう最悪 あなたどうするのかと
というと もう捕まっちゃったんだからね
まあ日本と違って先生のことをすっごく尊敬するんだからね
いくら年であってもね
ものすごく尊敬するし
怒鳴ったらじーっと下を見て聞くだけで
もう何もしません 言い返しもしません
だから転んでコラッ何やってるの？ただどうしようもなく
先生みんな出て行ったんだから
私も出て行こうかなと思ったんですよと
ああそう なんで？だって先生は寝ていらっしゃったんだからと
あのね 私が寝ても歴史は寝ませんよ
これは有名なことになっちゃったんです
私は寝たんだけど 歴史は寝ませんよと
だからそれすごい頭のいい人とそういうことなんです
寸時も大事なことは言っちゃうんです
だからその言葉だけ残って先生は亡くなってますけど
だから言いたいのは 毒蛇であっても取り扱い知っているプロには問題はありません
人間みんな財産使わなくちゃいけないでしょうに
人間だから 財産がなかったら生きていられないでしょうに
家が必要でしょうし 家族が必要でしょうし
子供がいるでしょうし
仕事があるでしょうし
全て財産というものに入りますよ
だから誰にも確実に使わなくちゃいけないものに知識がないといえば話にならんでしょ
取り扱い方わかりませんと
だから 財産に対して取り扱い方を知る必要はもう必須ですよ
これは必ず知らなきゃいけないものなんです
それで お釈迦様は一言葉毒蛇ですよと
だからものすごく注意しなさいよということで
なぜならば人は財産のせいで人殺したりする
強盗したりする もうなんて放火事件あったでしょ
日本であっちこっちで
これも財産の原因は財産でしょ
誰かさんになんかお金貸してくれなかったって
これで金融関係のところにガソリン撒いて放火したケースもあったでしょうに
親と怒って家に火をつけたりする場合もあるでしょうに
だからまあ放火するは
人殺しするは 強盗するは
戦争するは あらゆる悪いことは財産の取り扱い間違いで